Hertz broken spider-man fans have
received a little fatherly wisdom to
help ease the pain
Dominic Holland comedian author and
father of Spidey actor Tom Holland
recently took to his blog to offer up
his thoughtful take on the prospect of
the beloved character potentially
editing the Marvel Cinematic Universe
following an impasse between Marvel
Studios and rights-holder Sony Pictures
the Elder Holland reminded fans in his
August 21st post that they likely
haven't seen the last of his son Spidey
and that's in the end the factor which
likely precipitated the split will be
the same one that ensures that their
favorite hero returns to the screen
money my eldest son is owned by the
world now yeah but he still my little
little lad and after look after him
Holland explained that he'd been asked
for his own take on the situation by
multiple media outlets but had politely
declined for his blog readers however he
felt compelled to comment and he
portrayed just a touch of scorn for the
big Hollywood power players who had
failed to get a new deal done for the
fans writing I have no inside track on
such issues but whatever is decided by
the big suits of these big Hollywood
studios my hunch is that the show will
continue to much is at stake and too
many dollars riding on it
and besides everyone wants the same
thing mainly spider-man on large screens
keeping people safe and entertained and
with Tom in the suit for the time being
at least and in the years ahead no
doubts with another lucky actor in the
role just a day later the self-described
friendly neighborhood father of Tom
Holland felt the need to clarify his
statement due to the deluge of headlines
which followed his initial post he wrote
that he held no animosity towards either
party and he appeared slightly arrghh to
the possibility that such
misrepresentations of his comments could
reflect poorly on his son writing as I
said in the post I know nothing and my
only speculation remains that spider-man
will go on saving people and keeping us
all entertained in fact Tom Hollands dad
has not even spoken with Tom Holland
since the seismic story broke and he
certainly is not taking any sides he is
not calling for any boycotts and he
would not be storming any offices
anytime soon these headlines are just
click baits
a salacious headline to create website
traffic pollen close of a pointed
parting shot at those who had twist his
words for cliques followed by a bit of
characteristically British self-effacing
humor the Elder Holland wrote the
misrepresentation is shameful and not
some
I would ever stoop to until I consider
that I posted a blog on the subject
knowing that it might increase traffic
to my site so am i any better maybe not
but I am not that stupid I would ever do
anything to compromise my family and
involving myself in some things so far
above my paygrade immediately springs to
mind
spider dad is certainly taking the high
road here and so far has sent us no
comment on the matter he's continued to
post on social media without any mention
of the split but if comments he's made
previously are any indication he's
probably not too psyched about her
consider Holland's words when asked
about the possibility of a Spider Man
meeting up with Tom Hardy's venom whose
adventures take place and the wholly
distinct Sony universe of Marvel
characters in 2017 I'd love to make a
movie with Tom Hardy and if we ever got
to the charge to make a venom movie
together that would be super cool but
his movie would have to take place in
the MCU because I'm not giving up my
ticket
well some if Sally appears that you may
not have a choice but it also appears
that your dear old dad raised you well
because you appear to be approaching a
situation with the same level head
degeus it's a delicate matter and
immediately going public with ill-chosen
Polly thoughts our words would be well
irresponsible and as we all know with
great power comes great responsibility
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]